It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务正在快速扩张。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有顶级优先数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂巢最繁忙的时候，我的连接依然稳固。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是一个不会一直有的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐吧。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. people, the word solitude conjures up images of monks, hermits, wilderness retreats, and other extreme examples of spending time alone. But in reality, solitude is a common, maybe even an everyday experience. Some research has found that the average American adult spends up to one-third of their waking hours alone. In recent years, psychologists have been exploring how these hours spent on our own affect us, including the potential benefits as well as the challenges of solitude. And they're finding that being alone can offer us a needed opportunity for rest and reflection.
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负载时段不受数据流量降速限制。对于人们来说，“独处”这个词会让人联想到僧侣、隐士、荒野静修以及其他极端形式的独自生活。但实际上，独处是一种普遍的，甚至可能是每天都会发生的体验。一些研究发现，美国成年人平均每天有三分之一的清醒时间是独自度过的。近年来，心理学家一直在探索这些独自度过的时间如何影响我们，包括独处带来的潜在益处以及挑战。他们发现，独处可以为我们提供必要的休息和反思机会。
So what is the difference between loneliness and being alone? Do you have to be physically alone to experience solitude or can you be alone in a crowd? How does alone time affect our emotions and stress levels? Why do some people seem to crave solitude more than others do? And how can we balance the need for solitude with fostering the social connections that are essential for mental health? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the relationship between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. We have two guests today. First is Dr. Twyvi Nguyen, an associate professor of psychology and principal investigator of the Solitude Lab at the University of Durham in the UK.
那么，孤独感（loneliness）和独自一人（being alone）有什么区别呢？你必须在物理空间上独自一人才能体验独处吗？还是说你可以在人群中感到孤独？独处时间如何影响我们的情绪和压力水平？为什么有些人似乎比其他人更渴望独处？我们又该如何在对独处的需求与培养心理健康所必需的社交联系之间取得平衡？欢迎收听《心理学对话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的关系。我是主持人金·米尔斯。今天我们有两位嘉宾。第一位是杜威·阮博士，她是英国杜伦大学心理学副教授，也是独处实验室的首席研究员。
She and her colleagues study how spending time alone affects people's mood, stress levels, sense of loneliness, and more. She's interested in exploring both the positive and negative aspects of spending time alone, and how we can all have healthier relationships with solitude. Next is Dr. Netta Weinstein, a professor of psychology at the University of Reading in the UK. She's also director of the European Research Council's SOAR project, which stands for solitude, alone, but resilient. Dr. Weinstein has a background in clinical and social psychology and studies the role that motivation plays in shaping behavior and well-being.
她和同事们研究独自度过时间如何影响人们的情绪、压力水平、孤独感等等。她热衷于探索独自度过时间的积极和消极方面，以及我们如何才能与独处建立更健康的关系。下一位是内塔·温斯坦博士，她是英国雷丁大学的心理学教授。她同时也是欧洲研究委员会 SOAR 项目的主任，该项目代表“独处、孤身但有韧性”。温斯坦博士拥有临床和社会心理学背景，研究动机在塑造行为和幸福感中的作用。
Dr. Nguyen, Dr. Weinstein, thank you for joining me. Thank you for having us on. Yeah, thank you for having us. I should also mention that you both, along with a journalist and researcher, Heather Hansen, are co-authors of a new book called Solitude, The Science and Power of Being Alone, published in April by Cambridge, University Press. So let's start by talking about the distinction between solitude and loneliness. How do you define solitude in the work that you do? When we study solitude, we're talking
阮博士、温斯坦博士，感谢你们的到来。谢谢邀请我们。是的，谢谢邀请。我还应该提到，你们两位与记者兼研究员希瑟·汉森共同撰写了一本新书，名为《独处：独自一人的科学与力量》，由剑桥大学出版社于四月出版。那么，让我们从区分独处和孤独感开始谈起。在你们的工作中，你们是如何定义独处的？当我们研究独处时，我们谈论的是
kind of simply about the state of being physically alone, having nobody around, and not interacting with anybody digitally or in person. So when we tend to talk about solitudes, simply the experience of being alone, the state of being alone. Now, what about the distinction between solitude and loneliness. There's been a lot of public discussion lately about loneliness in the U.S. Our surgeon general, Dr. Vivick-Murthy, released a report last year calling out a loneliness epidemic among Americans. But you make the point in your book that solitude is not the same as loneliness. So how do they differ? So after the definition that NETA has given us, very much loneliness is more like us related to our social experience. So that
简单来说，就是物理上独自一人的状态，周围没有人，也没有通过数字方式或面对面与任何人互动。所以当我们谈论独处时，通常指的就是独自一人的体验，独自一人的状态。那么，独处和孤独感之间的区别是什么呢？最近公众对美国孤独感问题的讨论很多。我们的卫生局局长维韦克·默西博士去年发布了一份报告，指出美国人中存在孤独感流行病。但你们在书中指出，独处并不等同于孤独感。那么它们有何不同呢？在内塔给出的定义之后，孤独感确实更多地与我们的社交体验有关。所以那
That's usually how the best way for us to explain to people is because when we see that our social experience in reality doesn't match with our expectation. So with that definition of loneliness, then it's easy for people to distinguish between solitude, which is just a state of when you're not interacting with another person. And when you feel lonely, and that is when you feel like the social world doesn't match with what you want to be. And I think just to add a little bit to that, I think one of the important things that we tend to forget
这通常是我们向人们解释的最佳方式，因为当我们发现现实中的社交体验与我们的期望不符时，就会产生孤独感。有了这个孤独感的定义，人们就很容易区分独处——这仅仅是一种不与他人互动的状态——和感到孤独——即当你觉得社交世界与你想要的状况不符时。我想补充一点，我认为我们往往会忘记的一件重要事情是
is we can feel lonely when we're in solitude, but we can also feel lonely when we're with other people. So actually, if you think about the emotion of loneliness, negative emotion, it signals that we're disconnected. It's not something that's unique to solitude. It's something that can happen whether or not we're with people. So Dr. Nguyen, you've done lab studies where you've looked at how spending even a brief,
我们可以在独处时感到孤独，但我们也可以在与他人在一起时感到孤独。实际上，如果你思考孤独感这种负面情绪，它是在发出我们与外界断联的信号。它并非独处所独有，无论我们是否与人在一起，它都可能发生。那么阮博士，你做过实验室研究，观察过即使是短暂的
period of time alone affects people's emotions and state of mind. Can you talk about that research? What did you find? Basically, when we try to put people into the lab, we decide like a short period so that we can study just the effect of solitude on people's emotion. So I want to make it clear that the decision of just pick a very short period, either 15 to 30 minutes, is so that we can distinguish from other phenomenon that people have studied, things like isolation or loneliness is usually researchers studies those concepts in longer period from four hours for young people to 10 hours for an average adult. So when I put people in the room for just 15 to 30 minutes, what we often observe is how we have different emotion,
独自度过的时间如何影响人们的情绪和心态。你能谈谈那项研究吗？你发现了什么？基本上，当我们尝试将人们带入实验室时，我们设定了一个很短的时间段，以便研究独处对人们情绪的影响。我想明确一点，选择一个非常短的时间段（15 到 30 分钟）是为了将其与人们研究过的其他现象区分开来，比如隔离或孤独感，研究人员通常会在更长的时间段内研究这些概念，从年轻人的 4 小时到普通成年人的 10 小时不等。所以当我把人们关在房间里仅仅 15 到 30 分钟时，我们经常观察到的是我们如何拥有不同的情绪，
different type of emotion. And psychologists, we think of, often think of emotion as two dimensions. One is either go from negative emotion to positive emotion, which is generally what we tend to think of emotions. But there's also another dimension is from the low in activation and high in activation, or low in arousal, a higher larausal. So the beginning of all these lab studies, we tend to just see that the emotions that are high an arousal drop after we spend those brief period of solitude. And then sometime we also see some of the low arousal type of emotion. So we're talking about calm and relaxation also goes up.
不同类型的情绪。作为心理学家，我们通常认为情绪有两个维度。一个是负面情绪到正面情绪，这通常是我们倾向于认为的情绪维度。但还有另一个维度，是从低激活到高激活，或者说低唤醒到高唤醒。在所有这些实验室研究的开始，我们往往会看到，在度过这些短暂的独处时间后，高唤醒的情绪会下降。有时我们也会看到一些低唤醒类型的情绪。所以我们谈论的平静和放松也会上升。
And when I mentioned earlier about those strong high arousal emotion, we're talking about things like, you know, excitement, energizations, things that we, you can imagine experience at like a party or concert. but it also include emotions like anger, anxiety as well. So when we think about the effect of solitude, previous research tend to focus more on the drop in those high energy, positive emotion. And we forget that solitude can also help us to calm down those strong negative emotion as well, so that including our anxiety, stress, anger. But can you feel strong emotions when you're alone, when you're in solitude?
当我之前提到那些强烈的高唤醒情绪时，我们谈论的是像兴奋、活力这样的东西，你可以想象在派对或音乐会上体验到的那种。但它也包括愤怒、焦虑等情绪。所以当我们思考独处的影响时，之前的研究倾向于更多地关注那些高能量、正面情绪的下降。而我们忘记了独处也可以帮助我们平复那些强烈的负面情绪，包括我们的焦虑、压力和愤怒。但是，当你独自一人、处于独处状态时，你能感受到强烈的情绪吗？
That's a possibility, and that's why researchers, like, on the topic of solitude, we tend to try to identify situation where those strong emotion can come up. And usually those are when people might have negative thoughts or ruminative thoughts that arise when they spend time alone. But the tricky part is sometimes I also find evidence in the recent work that people tend to prefer solitude when they experience those strong negative emotion. So we don't know if it is solitude that create those emotion or people going into solitude when they experience those emotion with the purpose
这是有可能的，这就是为什么像我们这样研究独处课题的研究人员，倾向于尝试识别那些强烈情绪可能出现的场景。通常，当人们独自度过时间时，可能会产生负面想法或反刍思维。但棘手的部分在于，我在最近的工作中也发现，当人们经历那些强烈的负面情绪时，他们往往更倾向于独处。所以我们不知道是独处创造了这些情绪，还是人们在经历这些情绪时为了
to kind of calm themselves down. So that is an empirical question we need to look at next. Yeah. I see you nodding, Dr. Weinstein. This all resonates with you. Yeah, absolutely. You know, I think just like social interactions, will often think about having these great relationships, great conversations with other people.
平复自己而选择进入独处状态。所以这是一个我们需要在接下来研究的实证问题。是的，我看到你在点头，温斯坦博士。这一切都引起了你的共鸣。是的，绝对。你知道，我认为就像社交互动一样，我们通常会想到与他人建立良好的关系、进行精彩的对话。
You know, those conversations that leave us feeling excited and happy or angry or more relaxed. And in a way, solitude's a little complicated in much the same way that relationships are. You know, we can have strong feelings in solitude. It might help to bring us a sense of calm, but it doesn't mean it always will. And what we bring into it is really important. and certainly how we experience it, you know, what we're doing in those moments, how we're thinking, how we're dealing with their own emotions, all of those things are going to shape the solitude experience,
你知道，那些让我们感到兴奋、快乐、愤怒或更加放松的对话。在某种程度上，独处和人际关系一样复杂。你知道，我们在独处时可能会有强烈的感受。它可能有助于给我们带来平静感，但这并不意味着它总是如此。我们带入其中的东西非常重要。当然，我们如何体验它，你知道，我们在那些时刻在做什么，我们如何思考，我们如何处理自己的情绪，所有这些都会塑造独处体验，
much in the same way that they shape our relationships with other people. Are there some emotions that you would never feel in solitude? For example, I've read that when you're by yourself, you can't be embarrassed. Is that true? I think in the literature, it is distinguished between also social emotions. So I definitely, I don't think that we have looked at it. But for example, even when I collect data, I try to kind of think about also some emotion that if we give participants, it would not be possible for them to answer the question. Things like, for example, embarrassed.
就像它们塑造我们与他人的关系一样。有没有一些情绪是你永远不会在独处时感受到的？例如，我读到过，当你独自一人时，你不会感到尴尬。这是真的吗？我认为在文献中，它也区分了社交情绪。所以我肯定不认为我们已经研究过这一点。但例如，即使我在收集数据时，我也尝试思考一些情绪，如果我们将这些情绪提供给参与者，他们可能无法回答这个问题。比如，尴尬。
I think sometimes things like shame is also questionable, feeling ashamed. But I don't discount that sometimes we might. feel ashamed when we feel alone if we kind of recount those experience. And if I can just add, because I think it's a fascinating question, and it sort of speaks to what happens to us, what our internal experiences when we're in solitude, because I think one of the things that we're finding is that we do carry the experiences that we have into solitude, and even ones that we don't often think of. So one of the sort of surprising findings in some of the daily diary studies, where we ask people kind of about,
我认为有时像羞耻感这样的东西也是值得怀疑的，感到羞愧。但我不排除有时我们可能会在感到孤独时感到羞愧，如果我们回顾那些经历的话。如果我可以补充一点，因为我认为这是一个引人入胜的问题，它在某种程度上说明了当我们处于独处状态时，我们的内心体验发生了什么，因为我认为我们发现的一件事是，我们确实将我们所拥有的经历带入了独处中，甚至是我们通常不会想到的那些。所以，在一些日常日记研究中，当我们询问人们关于
how is your solitude today? What kind of experiences did you have? What kind of emotions did you have? And what we find is that even when we look at things like relatedness to other people or that sense of social connection, that we take that social connection into solitude. So we can still be in solitude and feel connected to other people. And it speaks to, you know, I think this is an area where we really need more evidence. But it sort of speaks to the possibility that a lot of those relationships and interactions we have, that we're carrying those memories, we're carrying the kind of symbolized people in our lives into our solitude space. And so we might reflect back to something we did that maybe felt, you know, shameful to us or was embarrassing and recall and kind of recreate that emotion in the solitude space, even when there's nobody there to sort of give us more of that
你今天的独处感觉如何？你有什么样的经历？你有什么样的情绪？我们发现，即使当我们观察与他人的关系或那种社交联系感时，我们也会把那种社交联系带入独处中。所以我们仍然可以在独处时感到与他人的联系。这说明了，你知道，我认为这是一个我们确实需要更多证据的领域。但这在某种程度上说明了我们拥有的许多关系和互动，我们带着那些记忆，我们带着生活中那些象征性的人进入了我们的独处空间。所以我们可能会反思我们做过的一些事情，也许让我们感到羞耻或尴尬，并在独处空间中回忆并重现那种情绪，即使那里没有人来给我们那种
feeling. Many people feel uncomfortable with the idea of going out to dinner or to a movie by themselves, even if they might enjoy it. Why do you think that there's some stigma around the idea of solitude of being out in public alone? So in the book, we kind of cover some of the historical context that might shape our schema or the norms that we usually carry about this experience called solitude. We talk about how, like, historically, we tend to see solitude talked about as more of a form of punishment. So in the past, it might be people being in exile, being casted out from society, even the extreme case of solitary confinement, and more of the recent practice we see things like timeout that we use for children. So with all that, I think we discussed in
感觉。许多人对独自外出就餐或看电影的想法感到不舒服，即使他们可能很享受。你认为为什么公众对独自一人在公共场合存在某种污名化？在书中，我们涵盖了一些可能塑造我们对独处这种体验的图式或规范的历史背景。我们谈到了历史上，我们倾向于将独处视为一种惩罚形式。所以在过去，它可能是人们被流放、被逐出社会，甚至是极端情况下的单独监禁，以及我们最近对儿童使用的“暂停”练习。有了这些，我想我们讨论了
about how that might shape our idea and perceptions around solitude, and that can make it a pretty fearful experience. And we do see that even like with qualitative interview, people talking about how when they are alone in public, there's the certain feeling of being judged. People might kind of generalize the momentary solitude to who they are as a person. What does it mean when I don't have someone to spend time with on this Friday night out in the city, in this restaurant? Does that mean I'm a loner? And then sometimes also not just, I think not just the person, but also people around us. I think there's, because we talk about work in the books, how there's women sometime out in public space might experience gays and judgment from other.
这可能如何塑造我们对独处的想法和看法，这可能会使它成为一种相当令人恐惧的体验。我们确实看到，即使在定性访谈中，人们也会谈论当他们在公共场合独处时，有一种被评判的感觉。人们可能会将短暂的独处概括为他们作为一个人的本质。如果我在这个周五晚上的城市里、在这家餐厅里没有人和我一起度过时间，这意味着什么？这意味着我是个孤独的人吗？然后有时也不仅仅是那个人，还有周围的人。我认为，因为我们在书中讨论了工作，女性有时在公共空间可能会经历他人的凝视和评判。
people. So yeah, so that's something that I think it's both the internalized fear, but also other people judgment as well. Yeah, and I think we see that as well in the language that we use for solitude. So, you know, I find that really fascinating that if we think about kind of the word solitude and what it means and sort of reflects the way that our society treats and has treated solitude historically. But I think it also might shape the way that we think. think about solitude that when you think about the word, it's not a word that just means being alone. It's a very simple concept and yet it still needs explaining. And that's because we tend to kind to kind of use the same word for solitude as we do for loneliness. We'll talk about sort of
所以是的，我认为这既是内在的恐惧，也是他人的评判。是的，我认为我们在用于独处的语言中也看到了这一点。所以，我发现这真的很迷人，如果我们思考“独处”（solitude）这个词及其含义，它在某种程度上反映了我们的社会如何对待以及历史上如何对待独处。但我认为它也可能塑造我们的思维方式。当你想到这个词时，它不仅仅意味着独自一人。这是一个非常简单的概念，但仍然需要解释。这是因为我们倾向于对独处和孤独感使用同一个词。我们会谈论
being solitary and that can be an emotional experience of being isolated or being alone. And again, the loner is a person who prefers solitude. So there's sort of something wrong in solitude as an idea in our head the way we symbolize it. And in English, we have the benefit of having the word solitude and the word loneliness. So, you know, researchers like Tweevy and I can kind of study those two things separately and think about those two things as separate. But in a lot of languages around the world, there aren't two words that, you know, mean solitude, the state of being alone and then mean loneliness.
独居，那可能是一种被孤立或独自一人的情感体验。同样，“孤独者”（loner）是一个喜欢独处的人。所以，在我们头脑中，独处作为一个概念存在某种错误，即我们象征它的方式。在英语中，我们有幸拥有“solitude”和“loneliness”这两个词。所以，像特威维和我这样的研究人员可以分别研究这两件事，并将它们视为独立的。但在世界上的许多语言中，没有两个词分别表示“独处”（独自一人的状态）和“孤独感”。
There's one word that's used interchangeably for both. So we don't even have a language to speak to solitude as a neutral and even positive experience. That's definitely true because I could relate that to Vietnamese. We do not have a word for solitude. In fact, the word, every time I try to translate for my family to understand, we struggle a lot because the word itself just doesn't make sense to say that it's a positive state. That's interesting, and I think a lot of people don't see it in a positive light. I mean, I know there's research, for example, where people are put in a situation where they are alone,
只有一个词可以互换使用。所以我们甚至没有一种语言来将独处描述为一种中性甚至积极的体验。这绝对是真的，因为我可以将其与越南语联系起来。我们没有一个专门的词来表示“独处”。事实上，每次我试图为我的家人翻译以让他们理解时，我们都非常挣扎，因为这个词本身在说它是一种积极状态时根本讲不通。这很有趣，而且我认为很多人并没有以积极的眼光看待它。我的意思是，我知道有研究，例如，人们被置于他们独自一人的境地，
and then they say, you know, they would rather give themselves electric shocks than just be by themselves. Have you participated in research like that? We heard of the study. It's a pretty interesting study, but I think the general message, from that study is more about how a lot of us are uncomfortable with the idea of sitting alone without thoughts. And I think the researcher decided to demonstrate that with a more sensational kind of measures, I think. But yeah, so solitude is something that best doing rather than thinking. And I thought that was very interesting, like just people more comfortable having
然后他们说，你知道，他们宁愿给自己电击也不愿独自一人。你参与过那样的研究吗？我们听说过那项研究。这是一项非常有趣的研究，但我认为那项研究传达的总信息更多是关于我们许多人对在没有思想的情况下独自坐着感到不舒服。我认为研究人员决定用一种更耸人听闻的测量方法来证明这一点。但是的，所以独处是一件做比想更好的事情。而且我认为这非常有趣，就像人们在独自一人时更喜欢
something to do when they are alone. And so the question is, what are that something that we can recommend people to do. And I think two of these really right on this and just to kind of highlight that I think the evidence is showing that especially young people, if they can be with others, you know, they're quite happy to be with others, does mean that that's true for everybody all the time.
有事情可做。所以问题是，我们可以建议人们做些什么。我认为特威维在这方面说得很对，我想强调的是，证据表明，特别是年轻人，如果他们能和别人在一起，你知道，他们很乐意和别人在一起，但这并不意味着这对所有人来说一直都是真的。
There are times where solitude is needed, beneficial, appreciated, but there are quite a few times that it's not. And for young people as well, what the research is highlighting is that if they're going to be alone, they really do prefer to be doing something versus sitting alone with your thoughts as a special form of solitude that isn't always right for everybody all the time. We do find as people age throughout the kind of adult lifespan, they get more comfortable, both with solitude and with being alone with their thoughts.
有些时候独处是必要的、有益的、被欣赏的，但也有不少时候并非如此。对于年轻人来说，研究强调的是，如果他们要独处，他们确实更喜欢做点什么，而不是独自坐着思考，这是一种并不总是适合所有人的特殊独处形式。我们确实发现，随着人们在成年期年龄的增长，他们会变得更自在，无论是对独处还是对独自思考。
So a lot of the evidence based in younger people, we're still learning about what that means for people throughout the adult lifespan and what it means for kids. So these days, a lot of us will automatically just turn to our smartphones when we're by ourselves. I mean, can you really experience solitude if you're scrolling through social media? Or do you not get the benefits of solitude if you just take out your phone when you're by yourself because you don't want to be with your thoughts? So I did conduct like a set of studies to look at that. And it's kind of interesting is because so far the focus of my work is about the effect of solitude on emotion.
所以很多证据基于年轻人，我们仍在了解这对整个成年期的人意味着什么，以及这对孩子意味着什么。所以这些天，我们许多人在独自一人时会自动转向智能手机。我的意思是，如果你在浏览社交媒体，你真的能体验到独处吗？或者如果你在独自一人时因为不想面对自己的想法而拿出手机，你就无法获得独处的好处了吗？所以我确实进行了一系列研究来观察这一点。有趣的是，到目前为止，我工作的重点是独处对情绪的影响。
So if we, when we only look at that, it seems like picking up the phones, browsing through social media, doesn't really take away that effect that we call the deactivation effect, which I mentioned earlier about the drop in those strong high arousal emotion. So even when people sitting there browsing on the phone, that effects do happen. But what we found was just it takes away this opportunity for self-reflection. And that has been shown. So I found that in the data that we collected, but also the researcher of Virginia Thomas. She also found that in young people, how like that can interfere with self-reflection. and she discussed about how that can also interfere with this process of identity formation
所以，当我们只看这一点时，似乎拿起手机、浏览社交媒体并不会真正消除我们所说的“去激活效应”，即我之前提到的那些强烈的高唤醒情绪的下降。所以即使人们坐在那里浏览手机，这种效应确实会发生。但我们发现的是，它剥夺了自我反思的机会。这一点已经被证明了。所以我在我们收集的数据中发现了这一点，但弗吉尼亚·托马斯的研究人员也发现了这一点。她还在年轻人身上发现，这如何干扰自我反思。她讨论了这如何也会干扰身份形成的过程，
because self-reflection can be pretty crucial for that period of life when people are young and still discover themselves. But yeah. Just to add to that, though, that when we think about technology use, we'll tend to kind of clump it up into one thing. But actually, there are a lot of different ways to engage in social media. And so when we ask people to define some, solitude and research that I've done with Tweevy, that we find that people will identify solitude
因为自我反思对于年轻人仍在探索自我的生命阶段来说可能非常关键。但是是的。不过，我想补充一点，当我们思考技术使用时，我们倾向于将其归为一类。但实际上，参与社交媒体的方式有很多种。所以当我们要求人们定义独处时，在我和特威维所做的研究中，我们发现人们会认为独处
can be passively looking at other people's posts and things like that, kind of exploring the social world in an informational way. You know, what are other people up to? It doesn't disrupt the sense of solitude. It might mean it's a different flavor of solitude, but actually kind of actively interacting with others through social media is a different. Now it takes people out of solitude. So we talk both about sort of, I guess, taking in social media information, but also actively engaging posting or talking to other people where it becomes much more a relational experience. And again, these are different forms of solitude. And within all those experiences, you know, I think this is one of the things that we're still learning a lot about. But, you know, we could do those things in a way that is maybe a little more compulsive or we're doing it out of habit.
可以是被动地查看别人的帖子之类的事情，以一种信息化的方式探索社交世界。你知道，别人在做什么？这并不会破坏独处感。这可能意味着它是另一种风味的独处，但实际上通过社交媒体与他人积极互动是另一回事。现在它把人们从独处中拉了出来。所以我们既谈论吸收社交媒体信息，也谈论积极参与发布或与他人交谈，这变得更像是一种关系体验。同样，这些是不同形式的独处。在所有这些体验中，你知道，我认为这是我们仍在学习很多东西的领域之一。但是，你知道，我们可以以一种可能更强迫或出于习惯的方式做这些事情。
We can do it more mindfully. So my guess is that as we learn more about this topic, we'll learn that there are different ways to have solitude moments that are maybe interspersed by social media engagement or technology engagement. And some are more or less harmful or disruptive to solitude than others. Make every get-together chill. This Memorial Day, get up to an extra $1,000 off select top brand appliances like LG. Plus, get free delivery at the Home Depot.
我们可以更专注地去做。所以我的猜测是，随着我们对这个话题了解得更多，我们会发现有不同的方式来拥有独处时刻，这些时刻可能穿插着社交媒体参与或技术参与。有些比其他的对独处的伤害或干扰更大。让每一次聚会都轻松惬意。这个阵亡将士纪念日，购买 LG 等精选顶级品牌家电，最高可享额外 1000 美元优惠。此外，在家得宝（The Home Depot）享受免费送货服务。
Tackle pool towels and camp laundry with a large capacity washer and host in style with the fridge serving craft ice, mini craft ice, cube dice, and crushed ice. Shop appliance savings now through June 3rd at the Home Depot. Offer valid May 14th through June 3rd, US only. Free delivery on appliance purchases of $998 or more. The C store online for details. What about reading or watching TV or even listening to a podcast? Is that a disruption to your solitude? So that study I mentioned earlier, we did include like a reading condition.
用大容量洗衣机处理泳池毛巾和露营衣物，用提供精制冰块、迷你精制冰块、方块冰和碎冰的冰箱以时尚方式招待客人。即日起至 6 月 3 日，在家得宝选购家电优惠。优惠有效期为 5 月 14 日至 6 月 3 日，仅限美国。购买 998 美元或以上的家电可享免费送货。详情请查看店内或在线信息。那么阅读、看电视甚至听播客呢？那是对你独处的干扰吗？所以我提到的那项研究，我们确实包含了阅读条件。
Reading is actually very compatible with positive solitude, actually. Because to me it's very interesting how the difference between, you know, reading and kind of flipping through the page and just kind of read whatever there and you're able to basically reflect on the information. At least for me, engaging with things on social media is something a little more. fast-based and information keep coming in, but a lot of time depend things on the algorithm. You might see information just being fed to you, but not in a coherent way as much as you would have in a book. So I think the type of media also have different ways to kind of like feed stimuli into you when you spend time alone. And if anything, I think all these things as more of different forms of stimulation.
阅读实际上与积极的独处非常兼容。因为对我来说，阅读和翻页、阅读上面的内容并能够基本上反思这些信息之间的区别非常有趣。至少对我来说，参与社交媒体上的事情更像是一种快节奏的东西，信息不断涌入，但很多时候取决于算法。你可能会看到信息只是被喂给你，但并不像你在书中那样连贯。所以我认为媒体类型在独自度过时间时，也有不同的方式向你输入刺激。如果说有什么不同的话，我认为所有这些东西更多是不同形式的刺激。
And there has been work that also show that the fact that we pick up with the phone sometimes to engage in like social media or to even seek out information like what another mention can be a way to regulate stress and boredom during that time. So yeah, I do think that this topic is very interesting. One thing I found surprising in your research is that you found that introverts don't necessarily benefit more from solitude than extroverts. So how is our need for solitude related to introversion or extroversion or even other personality traits? Well, it's hard for me to think like and answer the question about introverts because I very much still want to invest. I'm still invested
而且也有研究表明，我们有时拿起手机参与社交媒体甚至寻求信息（正如内塔提到的）的事实，可能是调节那段时间压力和无聊的一种方式。所以是的，我确实认为这个话题非常有趣。在你的研究中，我发现有一点令人惊讶，那就是你发现内向者并不一定比外向者从独处中受益更多。那么我们对独处的需求与内向、外向或其他性格特征有何关系呢？嗯，对我来说，思考并回答关于内向者的问题很难，因为我仍然非常想投入。我仍然投入于
in introversion and extroversion even though that we haven't found evidence. Just because it's just in Intuitively, that's what we think about. When we think about spending alone is that introverts tend to, so there's data supporting that introverts spend more time alone than extroverts. So we're talking about the quantity of solitude and social interaction. And what we haven't found, so one of the paper that Net and I both published is we didn't find the correlation between introversion, extroversion dimension with enjoyment of solitude
内向和外向的研究，即使我们还没有找到证据。仅仅是因为直觉上，这就是我们所想的。当我们想到独自度过时间时，内向者倾向于……所以有数据支持内向者比外向者花更多时间独处。所以我们谈论的是独处和社交互动的数量。而我们没有发现的是——内塔和我共同发表的一篇论文——我们没有发现内向、外向维度与独处享受之间的相关性，
or engaging with solitude for meaningful and enjoyable purpose. So, and then when I think about that work, it's just kind of like, well, because we don't actually have a perfect measure of introversion. The current measures that are common in the field usually tend to treat extroversion as someone who is talkative, energized, happy,
或者为了有意义和愉快的目的而进行独处。所以，当我思考那项工作时，这就像是，好吧，因为我们实际上没有衡量内向的完美标准。该领域中常见的当前测量方法通常倾向于将外向者视为健谈、充满活力、快乐的人，
When introverts are basically just when you reverse code and that's the opposite of extrovert. So because of that, then we don't know if when we find either no correlation or even sometimes positive correlation between extroversion and enjoyment of solitude, is that just because there's some shared variance between this idea of extroverts being a happy person? and then because of that, then they can't just find themselves happy in either solitude, social interaction, or any experience that are engaged in their life. So that, to me, is more of a methodological limitation.
而内向者基本上就是当你反向编码时，那是外向者的对立面。所以正因为如此，我们不知道当我们发现外向与独处享受之间没有相关性，甚至有时是正相关时，这是否仅仅是因为外向者作为快乐的人这一概念之间存在一些共同的方差？然后正因为如此，他们无法在独处、社交互动或他们生活中参与的任何体验中找到快乐。所以，对我来说，这更多是一种方法论上的局限。
So because of that, we're not sure if we can speak inclusively about introversion, extroversion, and the enjoyment of solitude. Yeah, and just to add to that, because I think where quantitative studies can, you know, have you scratching your head. Qualitative studies can help sometimes. And this is an example that because when we've done interviews and ask people, so what do you think it is about you that makes you enjoy solitude for those people who said they enjoy it? People often say it's because I'm an introvert. So people will self-identify as introverts and kind of identify that it's that characteristic within them that makes them really like solitude. But you know, when we think about
所以正因为如此，我们不确定我们是否可以包容性地谈论内向、外向和独处享受。是的，补充一点，因为我认为定量研究有时会让你抓耳挠腮。定性研究有时会有所帮助。这是一个例子，因为当我们进行访谈并询问人们时，对于那些说他们享受独处的人，你认为你身上有什么特质让你享受独处？人们通常会说是因为我是内向者。所以人们会自我认同为内向者，并认为正是他们内在的这种特质让他们真正喜欢独处。但是你知道，当我们思考
how we tend to talk about solitude in the public, we'll tend to say, okay, definition of solitude is somebody who gets energy from being by themselves, right? So definitionally, I think our common understanding of what it means to be an introvert is somebody who likes to be alone. And so it makes a lot of sense that those are kind of linked in our minds. And what Twyvi was saying was right on, because if the way we measure, it actually is measuring a lot of different characteristics about us that kind of have very little to do with that, then each of those might affect our relationship with solitude in different ways. Now, you mentioned earlier differences in enjoyment of solitude based on people's age. What about other demographic differences? Do men enjoy solitude more than women or
我们倾向于如何在公共场合谈论独处时，我们倾向于说，好的，独处的定义是那些从独处中获得能量的人，对吧？所以从定义上讲，我认为我们对内向者意味着什么的共同理解是喜欢独处的人。所以这在我们的头脑中联系在一起是非常合理的。特威维所说的是对的，因为如果我们测量它的方式实际上是在测量关于我们的许多不同特征，而这些特征与此几乎没有关系，那么每一个特征都可能以不同的方式影响我们与独处的关系。现在，你之前提到了基于人们年龄的独处享受差异。那么其他人口统计学差异呢？男性比女性更享受独处吗，或者
vice versa? Do we know? Well, it's interesting because when we wrote the book, we talked about this. we and then I think the three of us kind of really try to advocate solitude practice for women as well so that you kind of see that a little bit of that advocacy in the book because we tend to because mainly because we tend to get questions from people that you know men being independent women being interdependent, So maybe men would be someone who enjoy time alone more, you know, talking about the idea of like the man cave and the bachelor being in his apartment or flat.
反之亦然？我们知道吗？嗯，这很有趣，因为当我们写这本书时，我们谈到了这一点。我们，我想我们三个人确实非常努力地倡导女性也进行独处练习，所以你会在书中看到一点这种倡导，因为我们倾向于——主要是因为我们倾向于从人们那里得到问题——你知道，男性是独立的，女性是相互依赖的，所以也许男性会是更享受独自度过时间的人，你知道，谈论像“男人洞穴”（man cave）和单身汉住在他的公寓或平房里的想法。
But then when we look at like history and also like description, they are all women who, there's hermits that are women. I think there's a word we use in the book, but I don't remember what it is, Nana. For female hermits. Yeah. Yeah. And so, but the interesting thing when you think about gender, and actually often when we talk about solitude, is that it's almost like you have to be a special kind of person to deserve solitude.
但当我们观察历史和描述时，也有女性隐士。我想书中我们用了一个词，但我记不清了，内塔。女性隐士。是的。是的。所以，当你思考性别时，有趣的事情，实际上当我们谈论独处时，几乎就像你必须是一个特殊的人才配得上独处。
So a lot of these stories, and I think that's especially true for women historically, is that a woman who sort of is kind of psychologically strong enough to handle solitude and not be corrupted or, you know, we can buy it in some way. it has to be kind of, you know, spiritually already pretty transcendent. So it's not for like the everyday person, even in those instances where we have these amazing role models. And when you look at women historically who've really kind of talked about solitude being important to them, they've sort of lived on the edge of society.
所以很多这些故事，我认为这对于历史上的女性来说尤其如此，就是一个在心理上足够强大以至于能够处理独处而不被腐蚀的女性，或者，你知道，我们可以以某种方式购买它。它必须是那种，你知道，在精神上已经相当超脱的。所以它不适合像普通人那样，即使在我们拥有这些了不起的榜样的情况下。当你观察历史上那些真正谈论独处对她们很重要的女性时，她们在某种程度上生活在社会的边缘。
So it's this kind of interesting thing, I think, with gender, but I think also in terms of how we think about solitude, you know, that we tend to kind of think about this. kind of transformative experience, it's not accessible to many of us. And yeah, for me, that's just always striking, given how familiar it is to all of us, that we have the split in the way we think about it and the way that we're all experiencing it. Just to speak to the kind of question of how do our different backgrounds affect us, and, you know, Tuivi might also know more about this and where the literature is out with it now, but from the studies that we've done and the kind of evidence we reviewed when we were writing the book,
所以我认为这在性别方面是一件非常有趣的事情，但我认为在我们思考独处的方式上也是如此，你知道，我们倾向于认为这是一种转化体验，对我们许多人来说是无法获得的。是的，对我来说，考虑到这对我们所有人来说是多么熟悉，我们对它的思考方式和我们所有人正在经历它的方式存在这种分裂，这总是令人震惊的。只是为了谈论我们的不同背景如何影响我们，你知道，特威维可能也更了解这一点，以及文献现在的进展，但从我们所做的研究以及我们在写书时回顾的证据来看，
the takeaway is really that there are no simple answers to kind of solitude being, for example, for individualist cultures, but not collectivist cultures. It seems to be recognized as kind of potentially having these benefits globally. It's also something that globally cultures might struggle with this. So there's this kind of, you know, shared experience. And I think we're only beginning to understand what that shared experience really is across the globe. And even for women where it's not, you know, always very socially accepted to be alone, you know, you hear stories of kind of women, even in the home taking a few minutes on their own,
结论确实是，对于独处是否例如适合个人主义文化而不适合集体主义文化，没有简单的答案。它似乎在全球范围内被认为具有这些潜在的好处。这也是全球文化可能都在努力应对的事情。所以这是一种，你知道，共同的体验。而且我认为我们才刚刚开始了解这种共同体验在全球范围内到底是什么。即使对于女性来说，独处并不总是被社会所接受，你知道，你也会听到女性的故事，即使在家里也会花几分钟独处，
even when they're meant to be sort of 24 hours on call for the kids and taking care of the family. So, you know, I think people have taken those, at least, brief moments to find solitude in everyday life and that it doesn't seem to be, as far as we can tell so far, culturally specific or bound to any specific kind of time in our lives or subgroup. Do people who were only children have more of a craving for solitude than those who grew up with siblings, or do we not know? I don't think we know, I think really, but we do have some hypothesis around how development can shape people relationship with solitude. And that's specifically related to the work of Donald Wiennacott when he talk about the capacity
即使她们被要求 24 小时随叫随到照顾孩子和家庭。所以，你知道，我认为人们至少利用了那些短暂的时刻在日常生活中寻找独处，而且据我们目前所知，这似乎并不是文化特定的，也不受限于我们生命中的任何特定时间或子群体。独生子女是否比那些有兄弟姐妹一起长大的人更渴望独处，还是我们不知道？我不认为我们知道，我认为真的，但我们确实有一些关于发展如何塑造人们与独处关系的假设。这具体与唐纳德·温尼科特的著作有关，当他谈论能力时
being alone, being built through throughout the person development, how, you know, if a child has more opportunities to engage with solitude. So he talked about how perhaps when the mom or primary caregiver, being away and doing some tasks next to the child, but the child get the opportunities to explore their environment and kind of just be alone in that space and feel safe, then that become a practice later on when the child grow up and also have a more healthy relationship with solitude. So we have seen literatures that talk about that,
独自一人，是在人的发展过程中建立的，你知道，如果一个孩子有更多的机会进行独处。所以他谈到了也许当妈妈或主要照顾者离开并在孩子旁边做一些任务时，但孩子有机会探索他们的环境并只是在那个空间里独自一人并感到安全，那么这在孩子长大后就成为了一种练习，并且与独处有更健康的关系。所以我们已经看到了谈论这一点的文献，
whether or not that has been tested, I think that would be something I'm not aware that anyone has, anyone has tracked it, longitudinally. I think the closest we have is qualitative work. That's really, even then it's really early stages qualitative work, where people do talk about their early experiences shaping their relationship with solitude, but they will talk both about having big families where, okay, then I needed to seek out the space for myself. and also being, you know, the only child in the house and then having to learn to play by themselves.
至于它是否经过了测试，我想那将是我不知道有人追踪过的事情，纵向地。我认为我们最接近的是定性工作。即使那样，那也是非常早期的定性工作，人们确实谈论了他们早期的经历如何塑造了他们与独处的关系，但他们会谈论拥有大家庭，好吧，那么我需要为自己寻找空间。以及，你知道，成为家里唯一的孩子，然后不得不学习自己玩耍。
So it seems like our environment shapes our relationship in some way, but that we're bringing something into how it does that, you know, is kind of separate. There isn't a sort of one kind of the right amount of siblings or household members or privacy to be a sort of person who appreciate solitude. Oh, I want to kind of mention a story I read this week, actually, by someone sharing on Twitter a threat about how her development has shaped her relationship with solitude. And she mentioned about the idea of how if, you know, you were someone who grow up with parents whenever you do something wrong and you get put in time out, it's not really a way for you to develop that healthy relationship with solitude. And I thought that was really insightful. I think that kind of ties to the what we have talked about, about how this norms that we carry around this idea of solitude
所以看起来我们的环境在某种程度上塑造了我们的人际关系，但我们在其中所投入的东西，你知道，是相对独立的。并没有一种所谓的“正确”的兄弟姐妹数量、家庭成员数量或隐私程度，来定义一个人是否会欣赏独处。哦，我想提一下我这周读到的一个故事，实际上是有人在推特上分享的一条推文，讲述了她的成长经历如何塑造了她与独处的关系。她提到了一个观点，如果你是一个在成长过程中，每当你做错事就会被关禁闭的孩子，这其实并不是让你培养健康独处关系的方式。我觉得这非常有见地。我认为这与我们之前讨论的内容有关，即我们所携带的关于独处的社会规范和观念。
and how that can be shaped by our society, but also our development as well. And yeah, so I thought that's just something interesting to share. Well, talking about solitude as punishment, I mean, that is one thing that we use in prisons, for example, where we will put people in solitary confinement for long periods of time, sometimes years and years. What is happening to the health of such people? What do we know about long-term? What happens to people who are in solitary?
以及这些观念如何被我们的社会所塑造，同时也受到我们自身成长经历的影响。是的，所以我认为这是一个值得分享的有趣观点。说到把独处当作惩罚，我的意思是，这是我们在监狱中使用的一种手段，例如，我们会把人单独监禁很长一段时间，有时长达数年。这对这些人的健康有什么影响？关于长期影响我们了解多少？那些被单独监禁的人会发生什么？
Does everybody react to it in the same way? We both have a lot of things to say. I think about solitary confinement. but kind of a few reactions to that. The first is when we talk about solitary confinement, we're actually talking in a way about isolation, especially as you talk about these extended periods of time. And one of the fascinating things when you hear people talking about
每个人对它的反应都一样吗？我们俩对单独监禁都有很多话要说。但我有几点反应。首先，当我们谈论单独监禁时，实际上是在谈论隔离，特别是当你谈到这些长期的时间段时。当你听到人们谈论时，最引人入胜的事情之一就是
kind of more extreme solitary confinement is they talk about it being a very relational experience. So we think about people being alone, but they're put there by somebody. who's sort of saying, I have power over you. And, you know, because you've misbehaved or you've disobeyed me in somewhere, I'm not pleased with you, I'm going to punish you. So although it is solitude, it's kind of a type of isolation where that relationship with the guard becomes really salient and important.
那种更极端的单独监禁，他们谈论这是一种非常具有关系性的体验。我们认为人们是孤独的，但他们是被某人关在那里的，那个人似乎在说：“我对你有权力。”而且，你知道，因为你表现不好或者在某方面违抗了我，我不高兴，我要惩罚你。所以虽然这是独处，但它是一种隔离，在这种隔离中，与看守的关系变得非常突出和重要。
It's also often when people talk about difficult moments of solitary confinement or difficult periods, they'll tend to talk about solitary confinement that is also devoid of, you know, exercise, fresh air, nature, activities to keep the mind engaged, physical comfort, you know, warmth. So when we think about solitary confinement, we will tend to gravitate to really thinking about the solitude in it. But there's so much more that happens when people are put in solitary confinement than that they're separated from other people. And there's and research done with prisoners who have had short periods of solitary confinement in prisons that essentially care about prisoner rights where actually they feel that's a positive break
此外，当人们谈论单独监禁的困难时刻或困难时期时，他们往往会提到单独监禁还伴随着缺乏锻炼、新鲜空气、自然环境、保持头脑活跃的活动、身体舒适感，你知道，温暖。所以当我们想到单独监禁时，往往会倾向于只关注其中的“独处”。但当人们被单独监禁时，发生的远不止与他人分离这一点。而且，对那些在注重囚犯权利的监狱中经历过短期单独监禁的囚犯进行的研究表明，他们实际上觉得这是一种积极的休息，
from an intense social experience, sometimes one where I feel unsafe. So I'm not saying that we should kind of put more people into solitary confinement. And I think I personally don't have the expertise to say it one way or another. But I think that as well is not inherently about having some solitude time. It's about potentially having excessive, forced, and oppressive amount of solitude time. And having that be paired with a sort of, you know, kind of the aggressive, relational dynamic with the people who are in charge of the prisoner, as well as the kind of day-to-day experiences of being deprived of comforts.
可以从紧张的社交体验中解脱出来，有时这种社交体验让我感到不安全。所以我并不是说我们应该把更多人关进单独监禁。我认为我个人没有专业知识来断定这到底是好是坏。但我认为这本质上并不是关于拥有一些独处时间。它是关于可能拥有过度的、强制性的和压迫性的独处时间。并且这与看守囚犯的人之间那种咄咄逼人的关系动态，以及被剥夺舒适感的日常体验结合在一起。
Yeah, I agree with Nader that, like, the solitude in the context of solitary confinement is confounded by a lot of other factors around it. But when we, let's say, we take that solitude out and just study that in the lab. So there has been a group of researchers that did that. And, you know, I mentioned earlier about how when they study isolation, they quantify that as 10 hours of being alone, not interacting with anyone. So the effect of that is they show that there's a drop in our energy level. So, you know, of course, there's other outcomes like loneliness.
是的，我同意 Nader 的观点，即单独监禁背景下的独处被周围的其他许多因素混淆了。但如果我们把这种独处剥离出来，仅仅在实验室里研究它呢？确实有一组研究人员这样做了。而且，你知道，我之前提到过，当他们研究隔离时，将其量化为 10 小时的独处，不与任何人互动。结果显示，我们的能量水平会下降。所以，当然，还有其他结果，比如孤独感。
There's one interesting outcome that they measure is craving of social interaction. So that all makes sense. But the drop in energy level, I find that very interesting is because if we're talking about the effect of momentary solitude is drop in our strong emotion, then the extended period of that, that can have some implication for our energy. And if we think of ourselves as an organism that we do need, like, you know, a balance energy level, or talk about homeostasis, then that can't be good if, you know, a prolonged period and then our energy drop down and the implication of that.
有一个他们测量的有趣结果是对社交互动的渴望。这都说得通。但我发现能量水平的下降非常有趣，因为如果我们谈论的是短暂独处对我们强烈情绪的影响，那么长期处于这种状态，可能会对我们的能量产生影响。如果我们把自己看作一个需要平衡能量水平的有机体，或者谈论稳态，那么如果长期处于这种状态，能量下降及其后果肯定不是好事。
So I think when we think about solitude and distinguish that from isolation, which is an extended, period when we are cut off from social network and connection, I think that the length of time is pretty determining factors there is that if short period, you can talk about it as calm and relaxation, but in long period, that can't be good, which is like anything. I think it's all about balance. Yeah. Just to change gears a little bit, back in the late 90s of the early 2000s, there was a lot of discussion about this idea that was dubbed Bowling Alone, which eventually became a book, and Robert Putnam was the author. He noted how people were becoming less and less involved in face-to-face social interactions. Is there any scientific evidence that we're
所以我认为，当我们思考独处并将其与隔离（即我们与社交网络和联系断开的长期状态）区分开来时，我认为时间长度是一个决定性因素。如果是短期，你可以称之为平静和放松，但如果是长期，那就不可能是好事，就像任何事情一样。我认为关键在于平衡。是的，稍微转换一下话题，在 90 年代末到 2000 年代初，有很多关于“独自打保龄球”（Bowling Alone）这一概念的讨论，后来它变成了一本书，作者是罗伯特·普特南。他指出人们参与面对面社交互动的频率越来越低。有没有科学证据表明我们
becoming more solitary? And if so, is that a problem? I don't know of any evidence that would suggest that. You know, I think the nature of our relationships is changing. Arguably, this isn't the first time that it's changed. You know, I don't think humans have been holding their relationship kind of steady for 2,000 years and all of a sudden, you know, the last 20 years have happened and we're kind of fundamentally different. I think probably our relationships are always changing in the nature that we relate to others in our community, our families. So we're seeing shifts in the way that we relate, but at least I haven't seen any compelling evidence that we're kind of fundamentally becoming less sociable. I think our
变得越来越孤僻了？如果是这样，这是一个问题吗？我不知道有任何证据表明这一点。你知道，我认为我们人际关系的本质正在改变。可以说，这并不是它第一次改变。你知道，我不认为人类在过去 2000 年里一直保持着稳定的人际关系，然后突然间，你知道，过去 20 年发生了变化，我们就变得完全不同了。我认为我们与社区、家庭中他人建立联系的本质可能一直在变化。所以我们看到了联系方式的转变，但至少我还没有看到任何令人信服的证据表明我们从根本上变得不那么善于社交了。我认为我们的
sense of connection to other people is extremely important. I don't think anybody would argue with that and it continues to be the case so people will pursue opportunities for connecting with other people in the best ways that they know how. Yeah. The statistic that I'm aware of is just there's an increase in single person household. And usually that also tend to be mentioned in relation to the loneliness epidemic. But there's one argument by a sociologist that I found really compelling
与他人的联系感极其重要。我不认为有人会反驳这一点，而且事实依然如此，所以人们会以他们所知的最佳方式寻求与他人建立联系的机会。是的，我所知道的统计数据只是单人家庭在增加。通常这也会在提到“孤独流行病”时被提及。但有一位社会学家提出了一个我发现非常有说服力的论点，
was that he was talking about how that could be a correlation, but that doesn't mean it's a causation. It's because we might have, you know, the loneliness epidemic going on and we see more people. Part of that we don't know is just because we become more aware of loneliness, aware of the issues around mental health,
他谈到这可能是一种相关性，但这并不意味着它是因果关系。因为我们可能确实有“孤独流行病”正在发生，我们看到更多的人（感到孤独）。我们不知道其中的一部分原因是否仅仅是因为我们变得更加意识到孤独，更加意识到心理健康周围的问题，
and we see more of that being report. But in terms of the increase in single adult household, he was talking about how in the past, we kind of tend to have to rely on each other more for resources. And now there are, at least in developing societies, and we do see evidence of more single adult household in developing societies. Just because there are social services, there are more resource in terms of financial capability for people that allow people to live alone.
而且我们看到更多关于这方面的报道。但就单身成年人家庭的增加而言，他谈到在过去，我们倾向于更多地依赖彼此来获取资源。而现在，至少在发展中社会，我们确实看到了更多单身成年人家庭的证据。这仅仅是因为有社会服务，人们在财务能力方面有更多资源，这使得人们能够独自生活。
So I think a lot of that, there's other sociological factors that might explain that as well. Yeah. So what's next for you both? What are you researching now? You know, when we think about kind of solitude, for me, it's a place to build that relationship with yourself. And we're just learning about that. And if you think about going out and having a conversation with somebody else, they could be really unkind to you or they could be really kind, supportive or unsupportive, listen to your feelings or not. I think we can do the same kinds of things with ourselves and that it's that relationship in much the same way that you can be a good or bad friend.
所以我认为这其中有很多其他社会学因素也可以解释这一点。是的。那么你们俩接下来要做什么？你们现在在研究什么？你知道，当我们思考“独处”时，对我来说，这是一个建立与自己关系的地方。我们才刚刚开始了解这一点。如果你想到出去和别人交谈，他们可能对你非常不友善，或者他们可能非常友善、支持或不支持，倾听你的感受或不倾听。我认为我们也可以对自己做同样的事情，这是一种关系，就像你可以成为一个好朋友或坏朋友一样。
And whether we're good or bad friends to ourselves really could make a difference or kind of exploring those aspects of solitude. And also examining more about technology and what does it mean to pepper your solitude with social media time or have social media time intrude in solitude space? Can it have certain benefits and certain costs? So when the things that we're seeing is when we go on social media, it helps satisfy our relatedness. is the way we talk about it. We feel a sense of connection to other people. And that might help to explain why people are, you know, when they're in solitude or kind of jumping out of it and dipping into easy social interactions that they can have from the comfort of their couch or, you know, wherever they happen to be. And sort of what that means in terms of both potential
我们对自己是好朋友还是坏朋友，真的可能会产生影响，或者说是在探索独处的这些方面。此外，还要更多地研究技术，用社交媒体时间来点缀你的独处，或者让社交媒体时间侵入独处空间意味着什么？它会有某些好处和某些代价吗？所以我们看到的一件事是，当我们使用社交媒体时，它有助于满足我们的“关联感”，这是我们谈论它的方式。我们感到与他人有联系。这可能有助于解释为什么人们在独处时，或者从独处中跳出来，沉浸在他们可以从沙发上或无论他们身在何处就能轻松进行的社交互动中。以及这在潜在的
costs and benefits. And so I think those kinds of questions are really, really intriguing to understand how to sort of optimize our solitude time and also what can make it difficult. Yeah, for me, I'm kind of really fascinated about the idea of studying solitude and how that become kind of just like an essential part about humanity. Just because I think for a while, we tend to think of ourselves as social animal. And because of that intuitively, we tend to think of, when we without other people, when we're alone, then it's kind of like the opposite of that.
代价和收益方面意味着什么。所以我认为这些问题非常非常引人入胜，可以理解如何优化我们的独处时间，以及什么会让它变得困难。是的，对我来说，我非常着迷于研究独处的想法，以及它如何成为人性中不可或缺的一部分。仅仅因为我认为有一段时间，我们倾向于认为自己是社会性动物。正因为如此，直觉上，我们倾向于认为，当我们没有其他人时，当我们独处时，那就像是它的对立面。
So for a while, solitude doesn't fit into the idea of us as being social animal. So I think next for me is just kind of to dig into that idea and challenge it a little more. And just naturally, I tend to just gravitate it toward experimental design. And we kind of try to, for example, right now, thinking about how if solitude bring down our emotion. So in a stressful situation, what does that look like? And what are the factors that might play into that?
所以有一段时间，独处并不符合我们作为社会性动物的观念。所以我认为我接下来的工作就是深入研究这个想法并更多地挑战它。自然而然地，我倾向于倾向于实验设计。例如，我们现在正在思考如果独处能降低我们的情绪。那么在压力情况下，那会是什么样子？有哪些因素可能会影响这一点？
Like you said earlier, there are situations where those strong emotions might come up again when we are alone. But what contribute to that? Is it something that going on in our thoughts, in the behaviors that we do when we are alone? So to me, right now we try to zoom. in and kind of just say like what can we learn more about solitude to explain why we spend time alone if it is indeed that we are social animal.
就像你刚才说的，在某些情况下，当我们独处时，那些强烈的情绪可能会再次出现。但什么导致了这一点？是我们独处时的想法、行为中发生了什么吗？所以对我来说，现在我们试图聚焦，并说我们能从独处中学到什么，来解释为什么我们花时间独处，如果确实我们是社会性动物的话。
I think just to add kind of a big picture, you know, intriguing thing about the topic is one of the thing that solitude researchers are sort of highlighting is that a good day and maybe a kind of good life experiencing well-being that comes from having the very best of social relationships and the very best of solitude. So if we can take those two contexts for everyday life and sort of optimize them for ourselves, that's where we can gain them the most well-being. And some of that is, you know, how do they live in balance with one another? So we're having the right kind of amounts for us. But also, what do we do during that time? How do we take advantage of it? And, you know, for me, it's just really intriguing because, so Twivievi and I are both kind of
我想补充一个大局观，关于这个话题的一个引人入胜的事情是，独处研究人员正在强调的一点是，美好的一天，也许是一种体验幸福的美好生活，来自于拥有最好的人际关系和最好的独处。所以如果我们能把这两种生活情境结合起来，并为自己优化它们，那就是我们能获得最大幸福的地方。其中一部分是，你知道，它们如何彼此平衡地共存？所以我们拥有适合我们的正确数量。但同时，我们在那段时间里做什么？我们如何利用它？而且，你知道，对我来说，这真的很有趣，因为 Twivievi 和我都是
social psychologists of a clinical background. So we're very much tied into the social world. And can we come from a field where the interest is in relationships? How are we with others? How are others with us? And so psychologists have worked a lot to learn about that part of our lives. But there's this whole other world of solitude that actually we know so little about. There's so little research in this area.
具有临床背景的社会心理学家。所以我们与社会世界紧密相连。我们来自一个对人际关系感兴趣的领域。我们与他人相处得如何？他人与我们相处得如何？所以心理学家已经做了很多工作来了解我们生活中那一部分。但还有一个完整的独处世界，实际上我们知之甚少。这个领域的研究太少了。
so few solitude researchers compared to the relationships researchers that are out there. So, you know, I think it's just an area where there are a lot of questions still, and we're learning a lot all the time. And so, yeah, it makes it a really kind of exciting, intriguing, and mysterious area of study. Well, this has been really interesting. I want to thank you both for joining me, and I wish you great luck and success in your future research endeavors. Thank you. Thank you. Yeah.
与现有的关系研究人员相比，独处研究人员太少了。所以，你知道，我认为这只是一个还有很多问题待解决的领域，我们一直在学习很多东西。所以，是的，这使它成为一个非常令人兴奋、引人入胜且神秘的研究领域。好吧，这真的很有趣。我要感谢你们俩加入我，祝你们在未来的研究工作中好运并取得成功。谢谢。谢谢。是的。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www.spokenof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening. the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何您获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果您喜欢所听到的内容，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Weinerman 制作。感谢您的收听。美国心理学会。我是 Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。